if you had to brutally murder sweet
young girls what would you do you've
just found out that your job is not what
it seems and soon dozens of very
attractive trained Killers will be
coming to slaughter you and your friends
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the cute maid girls in Akiba made War
this girl is going to watch dozens of
cute girls get brutally slaughtered
nagami here has just arrived in the big
city and is dying to enroll in the most
dangerous job in the world being a cute
Cafe made girl heading to the Oinky
doink Cafe she tells this ponytail girl
that she's the new recruit and she meets
the manager named yasuko who runs the
cafe and gets changed into her new made
costume and wouldn't you know it she's
loving it but she also notices a much
older recruit there named Ronco no one
here realizes that this chick is an
ex-mate and will be responsible for
dozens of murders in the next few weeks
manager yasuko warns both of them that
they better not to disappear like the
last recruits they got that's strange to
say but anyways nagami doesn't think
much of it the cafe then opens up for
business and nagabi and Ronco test out
their made skills but end up sucking
really bad later at closing time trouble
comes knocking on their door this
headband guy enters and tells the
manager yasuko that the Oinky doink Cafe
is behind on their payments angry he
tells the mates that this Cafe is only
still open because of their connection
to the creature Land Group the most
powerful made Cafe in the area because
of this Cafe's failures headband guy
asks to borrow the new girl nagami to
run a special job for him a job so
special that it will cost the deaths of
dozens of cute Maids nagubi must deliver
an envelope to the creature land group's
biggest competitor before she can go
though Ronco interrupts everyone and
asks if she can come along and join
nagami for the job and manager yasuko
reluctantly lets her tag along stopping
by this Ramen Shop on the way they
grabbed dinner first oh how nice but
nagami doesn't notice that this Ramen
guy hands ranko a heavy steel package
heading downtown they reached their
target the wove Moonbeam Cafe and they
head inside but that's when they see one
of the girls in there getting spanked
for being a bad maid and it's right
about here that nagami realizes that
this Cafe is not very cute and that's
when she spots the big boss of this Cafe
walk over to them handing her this
envelope the lady opens it up and gets
really pissed off and nagami finds out
that the note inside basically insulted
everybody inside of this buddy Cafe for
no real reason and pisses off the boss
lady so much she slaps nagami hard but
suddenly she gets a big fatty put right
in her gray matter and the whole Cafe is
shocked and nagami's brain stop working
with all of the blood and Ronco quickly
gets her out of there but it's too late
all the maids there recover and take out
their made weapons and charge after
these two girls running for their lives
Ronco gets shot in the lake the two get
cornered I shouldn't like it but I do
this is what would happen if he let
Quentin Tarantino make an anime
adaptation of blend s manga and I'm
totally here for it moving on though if
I was nagami here I would have
recognized the signs that told me that
we were likely headed to the worst job
ever of Our Lives upon entering the cafe
first the manager said that one of the
best requirements a maid can have is her
young age but when commenting on Ronco
her being 35 was suddenly a non-issue to
the manager and she switched real fast
to focusing on motivation being the main
driving force of what it takes to be a
good maid that is a red flag to watch
out for when joining a company of any
kind when there's a lack of clarity or
consistency in the company values I
would have noticed that the manager in
reality had no real criteria that she
was looking for in new recruits and this
on top of the far away run down dingy
location r-made Cafe was in means that
in reality they were just looking for
anyone that would take the shitty job
and the headband loan shark guy who
entered shortly after would have further
proved my point that this Cafe was into
some shady stuff since it was obvious
that he came to collect these two signs
already could have given us the broad
picture of where this job was headed
even before we got tasked with that
suicide mission of delivering that note
being more aware of what was going on
could have also helped us have a backup
plan against these evil Maids because
taking on an army of maids while you
might think that's a really good time is
actually not it's a death sentence but
there is something that we could have
done the moment we left that evil Cafe I
would have used my environment to my
advantage because here's the thing Tokyo
and Japan itself is known for its
yokocho Alleyways which are basically
tightly packed bars and eateries that
are tucked away within the narrow
streets off of the main road and Akiba
being a popular tourist spot meets that
there would have been no shortage of
yokochill Alleyways and this means the
moment we hauled ass away from the bar
we could have ran down one of the
hundreds of Alleyways like this one and
could have darted straight into one of
these many small bars located within
these alleys and headed out the back of
these bars on her last leg literally
Ronco suddenly turns around and turns
into a Japanese John Wick it's amazing
go check it out and she takes out all of
these bastards like it's an art one of
the bunny Cafe mates survives though and
begs to be spared but Ronco tells her
that dying young is part of the maid job
and gives you a quick double tap nagami
watches in total shell shock and wonders
What The Hell she's just gotten herself
into the next day manager yasuko gets in
big trouble with headband guy again he
tells her that tanagami was supposed to
die last night so her death could be an
excuse for creature Land Group to go to
war with the cafe from last night the
wild wild Moonbeam Cafe but now no Gobi
has upset the delicate balance between
the maid cafes in the area and this will
cost them he warns manager yasuko that
if she doesn't want to die or Cafe needs
to make their payments soon meanwhile
poor nagami is still freaking the hell
out and doesn't understand how all the
other Maids are acting so calm about
what happened last night and one of her
co-workers with the tons of makeup on
her sees this her real name's chief on
by the way but I'm gonna call her
cakeface she sees not gonna be stressing
out so she tells her to go outside and
take a breather and the only way Cafe
Maids can by handing out flyers there
she thinks about running away from this
life but that's when she meets a maid
from another Cafe blue hair girl and she
is so nice to nagami and she convinces
her that there is so much more to being
a cute maid than brood of violence and
she also doesn't deny that it's a very
normal thing in their line of work and
somehow nagme gets really happy and
decides to gloss over that fact and
decides to not quit her dream job for
now so the next day nagami and ronko end
up bonding over maeve's duties when they
come across some businessmen outside and
one of them makes fun of ronko's wisdom
she's about to throw hands but she is
stopped by this Russian lady called Zoya
white she tells Ronco that Maids should
be cute and not violent she tells her
that she doesn't deserve to be a cute
maid Bronco finds out that this woman is
the head of security for these
businessmen as she watches Zoya lead
them all away not realizing that she'll
be forced to battle her in a death match
later tonight they then head back into
their Cafe when they run into headband
guy again he's back and demanding for
more Cafe payments but then he notices
ronko's bodaciousness and tells her that
if she wants to help her Cafe pay him
back he has a high risk job for her that
she could do and she accepts later the
maids head to the venue where Ronco will
perform and come across the fluffy light
and Sweet Cafe nagami thinks this job
will finally be cute and they enter and
see all the bloody cuteness live
terrifying matches between maids and
nagami is shocked and bakes Ronco not to
participate nearby manager yasuko meets
with this made boss of the cafe and she
tells her that they are trying to bring
up some of their Fighters so Ronco needs
to lose the next fight in the third
round if she does this some of the Dead
the Oinky doink Cafe owes will be wiped
clean from their slate manager yasuko
eagerly accepts the offer on her behalf
the match starts but Ronco easily beats
the reigning champion in seconds and
then she tells her team that oh by the
way she has a hard time pulling her
punches manager yasuko then gets in
trouble with the maid boss of this Cafe
and she tells her that Ranka will fight
again against another fighter of hers
but this time she must lose against her
in the final round if she doesn't she'll
kill all the oinky-doink maids right
here right now what am I looking at here
this whole thing looks like some sort of
Italian mobster doing uppercuts against
some Kawaii gangsters type of thing it
is so weird I love it but it's weird
anyways the whole solution to getting
out of here a lot is about as obvious as
cooking up an edible dish of fugu we
still might not come out of this alive
as our opponent being super evil looking
might still seriously harm us if we're
not careful if I was them I would
utilize the physics of our upcoming
Fighters attacks against them in order
to ensure that we will go down while
still taking the least amount of damage
possible by favoring defense over
offense and this can be done by
utilizing Advanced defense technique
known as rolling with the punches lame I
know but it does work on average a
straight punch generally reaches maximum
velocity at around 80 percent of the arm
extension that is why most competent
Strikers aim to put the opponent at the
end of their punch rather than too close
if we gauge the distance between us and
our opponent in the ring and maintain
ourselves at around 90 of their arm
extension length and since Morongo this
is totally possible because she's a
female John Wick in a maid outfit she
should be able to pull this off she'll
be able to ensure that the game-ending
blow that she takes will have the least
amount of impact possible also by her
rolling her head in the same direction
of the force of the punch doing that
will further help reduce the impact of
the hit that she takes and doing this
will allow her to go down and away that
might just save her life from getting
permanent brain damage doing this will
keep the boss lady happy and will
further Keep Us Alive for at least a
little while longer before the match
starts ronko's opponent Zoya white or
White Russian she tells her to kill
Ronco in the final round instead of just
knocking her out and she says yes boss
will do the boxing match then starts and
these two go had but as the rounds pass
by Ronco notices that Zoya White's
punches are starting to get more lethal
however though the two fighters end up
respecting each other through punching
each other to death and they both end up
thinking that they both deserve to be
cute Maids it's weird but Ronco manages
to knock her out and win the fight but
doing that pisses the boss lady off even
more Butch ends up dying a very brutal
death right after in a totally unrelated
maid deal gone wrong before she can do
anything but that's not important moving
on the girls end up right back where
they started they still owe money to
headband guy but they do find out that
Zoya has now joined their maid Cafe team
because she too wanted to live out her
dream of being a cute Cafe made a few
days later they find out some very bad
news manager yasuko has a new business
idea terrifying I know selling flowers
why because they need to pay back
creature Land Group within the month or
everyone else here will be marked for
dead a little bit later nagami meets up
again with blue hair girl and asks her
if she knows how to bring in more
customers to their Cafe she tells her
that by promoting fun parties at the
cafe is a good way to show off the
business and that they should team up
with an affiliate cafe nearby to have a
combined party so nagami runs the idea
by her Cafe and tells them that they
should have a party for one of the maids
here and invite everyone and Ronco tells
them that her birthday is coming up so
everybody prepares for her birthday
party worried that no one will show up
the next day nagami follows blue hair
girl's advice and she and Ronco head to
one of their sister made cafes to talk
with them and they enter the May cheap
Cafe and that was their biggest mistake
the manager of this Cafe approaches them
I tell them that today is her birthday
too and she makes fun of their shitty
flyers and she also convinces all of her
customers to join in too humiliated
nagami leaves with Ronco but the Sheep
Maids catch up with them and hold up
nagami at gunpoint Ronco tells them that
sister Maids harming each other violates
the maid code but this blonde mate tells
her that they pissed her off and now
they must follow them back to their
Sheep Cafe or else nagami will die as
they leave Oinky doing's panda seized
this and runs back to alert the cafe
inside of the Sheep Cafe nagami and
Ronco get tied up and this evil blonde
maid tells them that no maid can ever
have the same birthday as her no one can
and she's killed every single maid who
did this nut job then dropped a cute
sheep into their hole and begins
flooding the place with tomato juice
okay that is so not fair what did we do
wrong here nothing so annoying anyways
these guys did everything wrong from the
beginning and it makes no sense how
ronko being an ex-mate didn't think of
what to do as they were being tied up
once they were escorted back to their
Cafe it's likely that they weren't
unconscious when they got tied up they
could have still increased their chances
of escaping if they just positioned
their body and expanded their entire
frame to be larger than it was in short
my weebs I'm saying they need to take a
very very big deep breath and by doing
this it will artificially expand the
surface area of their frame and in doing
that they would have created more
potential slack in the Rope when they
let out their breath this trick would
have made it easier for them to escape
from the ropes in the first place once
freed from the chairs immediately going
to push these chairs up against the wall
of this Barrel in order to stand on top
of it which will help stabilize my
balance due Toronto's height over us if
I'm nagami I'm smaller and lighter I'm
Going To Shimmy my way up onto ranko's
shoulders from here once on top of her
shoulders I would have a better shot at
reaching and even pulling myself up over
the Barrel's Edge allowing us from here
to begin to figure out how to help ronko
we could even run and call for help or
we could even run and never come back
and just screw ranko over altogether
because hey she's 36 years old and in
mid-year she's practically dead she's
already lived a fulfilling life and if
I'm nagami it's now my turn to live my
life back at the Oinky doing Cafe the
girls have planned a surprise party for
Ronco but find out from their Panda that
she and nagami are in trouble and they
rush to the Sheep Cafe and throw down
with these maids and they even managed
to rescue these two from nearly dying
rewarding Ronco with finally her
birthday celebration in the end later
all the made cafes in the area get the
worst news of all another maid has
arrived back in town Crimson Supernova
AKA level 1 Daddy but she's even more
crazy than the rest she was in jail for
the past 10 years and now she is out and
hungry for vengeance she heads to her
old Cafe that she used to run made alien
Cafe now run by this new boss old blonde
lady and the current boss is shocked to
see her out of prison and awkwardly
tells her that they've managed to come
close to defeating creature land and
it's only a matter of time until their
Cafe takes over town she also reveals to
level 1 Baddie that some of their
partner cafes Like the Wolf of Moonbeam
Cafe has been completely wiped out by
the Oinky doink Cafe and level one
Baddie gets pissed meanwhile though
manager yasuko gets in trouble with
creature land group's Big Boss we'll
call her something epic final boss Spade
yeah that works they tell her that Oinky
donkey Cafe has been causing too many
problems with other cafes recently aka
the wolf wolf Moonbeam Cafe because of
this their rival competitor the creature
alien group have launched a former
complain against them final boss babe
tells manager yasuko that her Cafe must
go settle her problems with the creature
alien group themselves or their Cafe
will get shut down so manager yasuko
rushes back to her Cafe and tells
everyone the bad news their parent
company has abandoned them and now they
must prepare to fight alone now Gumi
gets worried and tells them since her
friend blue hair girl belongs to level
one baddies made alien company she'll be
forced to fight her but manager yasuko
has an idea telling her that she could
make an official Sisterhood packed with
blue hair girl and doing this deed will
make blue hair girl nagami's official
maid sister preventing the two from ever
having to fight each other so what do
they do the two officially sister up
they also managed to convince blue hair
girl to spy on her Cafe oh that's
helpful later all of Oinky doing's rival
cafes get orders from Level 1 Baddie to
prepare for war against them level one
Baddie tells old blonde lady and her
Minions that they need to start
prioritizing strength over money and act
more ruthless as a company a few days
later nagami tells her co-workers that
blue hair girl has informed her that her
Cafe will attack soon and hasn't heard
anything from her since and now she
thinks she's gone missing Ronco offers
to help her find blue hair girl they
find out from steel package Ramen Guy
where she is going down this alley they
find her and she tells them that she's
hiding because her Cafe has found out
that she snitched on them but just then
trouble finds them and the level one bad
in her minions show up she tells the
oinky-doinker girls that blue hair girl
must now die because of her betrayal
nagami tries to defend her but blue hair
girl sacrifices herself right as level
one bad a shoots her full of lead police
sirens are then hurt nearby so level 1
Baddie and her minions quickly leave the
scene blue hair girl utters her last
words to nagami telling her that being
her sister was the best thing she's ever
done and she dies in a really not cute
way for really no important reason at
all one week later nagami goes into
hiding the onky doing Maids start
getting nervous and worried that the
level one Baddie will attack them soon
and Ronco decides to go find nagami and
spots her working in this new Cafe as a
ninja nagami pretends to not know her
but gets discovered in like five seconds
and tells her that she's given up being
a maid since blue hair girl's death so
Ronco gives her space and heads back to
the Oinky doing Cafe and informs
everyone where she is the next day at
the ninja Cafe nagami gets some new
customers sent by Ronka they tell her
that they were blue hair girls most
loyal customers and revealed that she
told them how nagami would make an
awesome maid one day and this chews the
out of nagami that night winky
doing Cafe is on high alert and spots
level 1 Baddie and her maid Army
approaching them and everybody gets
ready for a super weird bloody-made
battle the evil Maids enter the building
and are slowed down by ponytail girl
Ronco then tries to pop the evil Maids
off but they are straight up Savages and
shoot one of their own the evil Maids
overpower Zoya and cakeface as they
swarm the top floor and force everyone
to retreat into the cafe thinking it's
all over out of nowhere ninja nagami
comes out from the lift and Ninjas the
crap out of these evil Maids it's
awesome taking out some of the minions
as the rest of the good Maids get into
just about the filthiest cat fight we've
ever seen level one Baddie gets injured
and one of her minions forces her to
retreat while the rest of her henchmen
get picked off by the oinky-doink maids
nagami and Ronco then decide to follow
them okay this is all glorious but what
doesn't make sense is how unprepared
these girls were when it was clear that
they knew war was headed their way if I
was them I would have taken more
measures to better fortify this Oinky
doing Cafe let's get to the left leading
right up onto the cafe floor look at
this it was not working when the evil
mates tried it but moments later found
out that the reason for this was because
nagami was hiding inside of it however
the shock of mates tanagami being there
all that means is that they didn't know
she was there and means if it wasn't for
nagumi disabling the lift in the
beginning the evil mates would have been
able to take the freaking lift straight
into the cafe that just shows you how
unprepared they were but the fact that
Oinky dink is a part of an entire
building means that we could have used
the element of surprise since there were
no reasons we had to wait in our Cafe
for the evil maids to show up all's fair
in war level one Baddie chases away her
minions and takes some time to herself
and the Oinky doing Maids then find her
and Ronco prepares to kill her but
tanagabi stops her and tells her that
being a maid is more than just killing
so she gets pimp slapped by level one
Baddie for being so silly but monogamy
demands that level 1 Baddie feels the
cuteness inside of her taking time to
reflect this evil maid decides to give
up the fight and limps back to her maid
alien Cafe but later finds out from old
blonde lady that her and her sister
cafes have made a deal with their rival
company creature Land Group belonging to
final boss babe everyone here thinks
level one bad is too Reckless to be a
maid so they blast her to I'd end
up getting screwed over by a creature
Land Group in the deal making fun of
Boss babes company take over all the
cafes in the area later the funeral of
level 1 Baddie rolls around and manager
yazuko is forced to show up however
though final boss babe also shows up and
orders manager yasuko's Cafe to make up
with the maid alien Cafe they decide to
play a friendly game of baseball
together and nagami thinks this is the
perfect non-violent way to settle their
differences the next day the baseball
game starts but both teams consistently
try to hurt each other even nagami gets
injured but she is determined to be a
peaceful mate no matter what and slowly
manages to convince her team and her
opponents to begin playing fairly the
manager of the enemy Cafe gets angry and
pretends to join the game but tries to
her to nagami instead and she ends up
getting stabbed by their team's mascot
who they discover is an old follower of
level 1 Baddie and they quickly kill her
too nagami gets sad at all of this
killing entry cuteness convinces all the
maze to act as if nothing happened
because that happens in anime and they
all continue to playing the baseball
game as normal even though they all
committed murder again as both of these
corpses watch from the distance it's
really weird the Oinky doing Cafe
eventually ends up winning the game and
even some of the girls on the opposing
team end up having fun and nagami thinks
that she's made blue hair girl down in
hell route after the match final boss
babe finds Ronco and realizes who she is
shocked that she's still alive she gets
mad at her for not killing level 1
Baddie and thinks that she's gone too
soft before leaving she tells Bronco
that she's too old to be a cute maid
anymore and needs to fight for the sake
of their giant company or else she'll
have no home here anymore final boss
babe then gets in her car and discusses
with her driver how their plan to kill
the enemy manager has finally cleared up
all of their obstacles the next day all
the Mad cafes hold their famous maid
Festival where different cafes come
together to sell their merchandise and
where Maids will compete to be the best
of the best and final boss Vapes
creature Land Group tells all the
smaller cafes that her personal Cafe the
daz lion must win the event headband guy
then specifically warns manager yasuko
that her Cafe better follow the rules in
the rule book correctly but she soon
after loses the rule book and gives up a
bigger manager for good meanwhile the
Oinky doing Cafe sets up their food
stall but one of roncos best customers
from the cafe shows up and he tells her
that he loves what she's selling and so
she sells him what he loves and just
then the maids get fun of by the other
competing cafes and nagami has had
enough she tells her co-workers that
they're the best mate she knows and
deserve to try and win this competition
later that night though all the maid
cafes get ready for the second part of
this festival and get ready for a
violent race up to the top of this
statue they all get instructed to lose
to the Dazz Lions but are told to make
sure it's a close call so the public
doesn't find out that it's a fixed event
the race then starts but nagami's Cafe
disobeys the rules and tried their best
to win the game by getting to the top of
this statue and they run into the Dazz
lionmates who try to stop them but
nagami manages to climb near the top and
with ronko's help wins the game and the
entire Festival destroying final boss
Babe's delicate maid ecosystem okay
nagami your pep talk did great and
seemed to make for a good watch but what
she did was incredibly stupid because
nagami directly contradicted the
business Dynamics when it comes to
establishing a smooth and effective
Company by establishing their Cafe as
the best and beating final boss babes
Cafe they have indirectly outshined
final boss babe and this makes no sense
when you consider how insecure final
boss babe is she would likely do
whatever she wants now to them to punish
them what we need to do is impress the
people above us and give them lots of
gifts to make them feel super awesome
and appreciated the onky doing Cafe
started out at the bottom of the
rankings due to their trouble with
payments and the fact that they have no
allies within the main Cafe Community
they should have fought to try and come
in second or at least third place and
while this would upset final boss babe a
little bit this wouldn't upset her as
much as them winning like they did and
they could have credited creature Land
Group for all of their hard work for the
event and thank them for being their
boss see what I just did there now the
Oinky doing Cafe has now given final
boss babe a gift which will make her
happy she would have won and we would be
able to move on with our lives nagami's
hubris and ego is going to cost them in
the long term for just a short term win
with their crazy Victory the Oinky doing
Cafe gets instantly famous and final
boss babe gets Furious and kills
headband guy and manager yazuko finally
shows up and gives up on giving up and
stays on to be their manager over the
next few days the Oinky doing Cafe gets
loads of new customers and ronco's best
customer shows up again and finally asks
her out on a hot date and she discusses
it with manager yasiko but she tells him
that she thinks he's a banker which
means he's loaded so the girls totally
encourage Ronco to go out on a hot date
later the maids dress up Ronco to kill
for her date but tanakami has a gut
feeling and gets worried for ronko and
she meets up with him who will call
trench coat guy and they spend the day
doing a lot of cutesy date it's
nauseating and cute and a few hours
later they stop by this heater store and
trench coat guy tries to flirt like an
adult he tells Ronco that his Hero at
home has stopped working so ronko should
go to his place to help him warm up and
she tells him that they might just fall
asleep together if that happens but
trenchcoat guy says that's fine and then
he jumps the gun and declares his love
for her and asks if she wants to run
away with him tomorrow all night and
then he plants a big one right on her
lips just to screen the deal truly
romantic stuff and he tells her to meet
him at the train station tomorrow night
and leaves her but suddenly the only kid
doing Panda shows up and holds the gut
the panda then reveals that it used to
be a maid many years ago but was on the
verge of being fired her only loyal
customer at the time asked her to
perform an assassination on a maid from
a rival Cafe and to not wanting to lose
her best customer or her job she
completed the assassination and killed
that mate but that maid was ronko's old
manager the manager of this old Cafe
before it became wonky doing however
though after she finished the job her
loyal customer tried to kill her and
reveals that she was set up barely
escaping with her life and now on the
run she decided to stay hidden in the
panda costume all these years she
eventually became wonky doing's panda
mascot and tells Rango that she went to
prison for killing the wrong person
responsible for her manager's death
Panda girl tells Ronco that her loyal
customer who tried to kill her was in
fact trench coat guy and he's now
returned it's likely that someone sent
him to kill Ronco as well and Ronco gets
mad as hell but doesn't kill Panda girl
and tells her that her manager all those
years ago wouldn't want her to be so
cold and tells Panda that she'll deal
with trenchcoat guy tomorrow night
heading back to the Oinky doing Cafe she
tells Nagomi and everyone else that she
had a great date and she gets ready to
kill trench coat guy tomorrow the next
night ronko thanks anagami for showing
her what it means to be a cute maid but
then tells her that she is leaving
forever and she packs up her stuff and
heads up to meet trenchcoat guy but
finds out he's a no-show few hours later
she returns to the cafe and finds out
that Panda made killed a trench coat guy
for her and reveals what he told her
before he died and it turns out that the
one who gave him the assignment to make
panda made Kill ronko's old manager and
set up Ronco for murder was in fact
final boss babe and she tried to use
trench coat guy again this time to
murder ronko knowing that final boss
babe has it out for her Ronco tries to
lay low in the busy Oinky doing Cafe for
the next week but that's when they get
the worst news of all and find out that
creature Land Group has now officially
disowned them and without their
protection all of these maze will soon
get slaughtered and knowing that it was
her fault Ronco declares that she's
gonna go fix it just like Fix It Felix
and the rest of the girls decide to
support her in her Mission so ronko and
nagami hit up creature land headquarters
but gets stopped at the entrance and
held up at gunpoint at our taken to
final boss babe and ronko then has a
sudden change of heart and decides to
not try and kill her instead she begs
her company to take back oinkiton Cafe
for nagami's sake and final boss babe
decides to put some sense into Ronco and
takes nagami hostage telling her that
she can give her a better made position
at another Cafe if she kills nagami
right now but Ronco declares that
onkiton Cafe is her home forever and
that nagami reminded her of their old
Master frustrated final boss babe allows
them back into Creature Lance group and
everybody calls the truce but that was
their biggest mistake okay this is crazy
because right now these girls are up
against cycle and everybody thinks
everything is going to go back to be
hunky dory now it's not if I was them I
would not have taken any of what final
boss babe has said seriously because we
have to remember what her organization
is based on her organization is really
based in real world criminal Enterprise
and it does not rely on things like
honor and Free Will no no no they use
fear to instill real world to discipline
among its members means that most
successful crime families that are still
around Survive by making its members
know and fear punishment for what could
happen if they ever disobeyed the rules
and doing this guarantees unconditional
loyalty to the family or in this case a
maid Cafe and this means that we as
oikidoic Maids have not only acted as
dead weight to the organization since
the beginning now we've gone and
insulted final boss babe at the maid
Festival in front of everybody and up
until now we haven't suffered any
consequences that's gonna end unless
we're planning to kill her right then
and there we should have avoided her
because as a Crime Boss she is never
going to just forgive us for what we've
done there's no way out of this other
than for someone to Die the next day
nagami is out shopping with Ronco and
loves how everything has gone back to
normal but suddenly Ronco gets stabbed
and dies brutally right in front of her
and everybody is shocked as all the onky
doing Maids then go on high alert
creature Land Group eventually finds
ronko's killer being one of the
survivors that came out of the wove moon
beam Cafe but final boss babe spares her
and makes her a part of her team as she
decides to settle this drama once and
for all and declares war on the onky
doing Cafe meanwhile ronko's death has
turned to nagumi's Heart black and she
decides to become a much eviler maid in
order to avenge Rocco's death yes and
asks everyone to start calling her black
pork and she decides to go evil ham and
find ronko's killer and she gets some
information from this rival maid but
also gets Told By Ramen guys a little
more backstory behind final boss Babe's
past she grew up in the Mad Cafe as an
orphan where she met Ronco working there
years ago but ronko's cuteness turned to
their violent a manager into a
kind-hearted one unable to stand the
cuteness final boss babe paid an
assassin to kill their manager and frame
Ronco for her murder which sent Ronco to
jail and sowed like pork then heads back
to the cafe wanting Revenge but finds
some of her uncle's old belongings in
the room and sees all of her things
inside and this suddenly makes black
pork sad and she decides to go back to
being a cute nagami maid instead and
then tells the maze her plans to stop
the final boss babe later final boss
babe and her Army reaches the Oinky
doing Cafe and stomped to kill Ramen guy
real fast oh shoot homo Ramen expecting
a violent Showdown the evil Maids enter
with their hands on the trigger but
discover all the okidoic maids acting
all cute instead and they offer them the
maid Cafe experience first before
they're all going to die finding and
amusing final boss babe let them serve
her first while nagami puts on a maid
performance on stage and her moves
remind final boss babe of a younger
Bronco and this pisses her off and she
shoots nagami made to dance but nagami
keeps on dancing and the rest of the
wonky donkey mates keep on being cute
while crying about it it's glorious and
also sad and after final boss babe
shoots this evil maid to make a point
and tells the onky doing Maids they must
have no soul and need to be ruthless
because in the end they'll all end up
alone die nakami says that it's a maid's
job to serve the others help those in
need and be cute at all times and the
maids think they've changed final boss
Babe's mind but now she shoots nagami
four times right as she gets blasted in
the face and speared by Panda
fortunately though the onky dogs then
convinced the rest of the evil maids to
stop the violence once and for all in
honor of nagami's death fast forward 20
years later the maid violence has
stopped and three customers returned
agree to their favorite maid at the
rebranded Oinky doing Cafe right as the
cutest 36 year old maid rolls up to
greet her regulars nagami and if you
don't end up like no debut Cafe made
girl then like comment let us know what
you liked of course then like don't get
check out the how to be playlist down
below